what was space weather like in the past
space weather is basically what's going
on near the Earth but not actually in
the atmosphere so changing magnetic
fields charged particles streaming in
from the Sun what we call the solar wind
stuff like that this matters because
variations in space weather can affect
and even damage electronic equipment I
previously made a video about how you
can recreate past climates by clever
analysis of ice calls but did you know
you can do the same thing for space
weather you do so by looking for
cosmogenic radi nucleid radioactive
isotopes like carbon 14 and verillium 10
that formed when a high energy particle
in the solar wind hits an atom in the
Earth's atmosphere and Alters its
nucleus the stronger the solar wind the
more cosmogenic radio nucleid are formed
and in particularly strong events enough
of them are formed that they make their
way into snowfall in the polar regions
and so into the ice core record four
such events have been identified
approximately 1,000 1,250 2,500 and
9,000 years ago of course those all took
place long before Society became
dependent on electronics how we would
respond today to a solar wind event that
strong we simply don't know